just not you know our conspiracies get
me in trouble sometimes and make
headlines but
does nobody think it's weird that the
mazva doll drama remember he's gonna sue
him for you know uh hitting him outside
that Miami uh restaurant all that's gone
away do you think maybe the UFC Went to
went hey draw by that stuff you come
back with your title shot drop all that
[__] because when you have Mozilla
fight Gilbert Burns we need to move on
this can delay everything drop it and
we'll give you a title shot right
through the city like British
[Music]
kiddos it is March 20th uh uh Monday
morning Monday money Monday kicking the
nuts like a hard cup of coffee good to
see you guys quite the fights over the
weekend don't just say quite the fight's
over across the pond there over in
England
uh the fights did not disappoint let's
get right into it so for UFC 286 uh
clearly the main event is The Narrative
of the card with Leon Edwards Kamar
Usman three
um if you went back and listened to the
breakdown of UFC 286 of Camaro and Leon
Edwards from last week's show I uh had
picked Leon Edwards
um so I was right on that uh I had
physiv over gaichi it was wrong on that
uh Gunner uh did it work vittori did
work Jack Shore Jackie boy Shore whales
finest Wales with a h okay not with an a
um then also I thought my my MVP I told
you guys to watch out from was that
Christian Leroy Duncan unfortunately we
didn't get to see the full display of
Christian because homeboy blew his knee
out so that was uh not the way I wanted
to start off my S my birthday on
Saturday but the way I want to kick it
off I want to see let you guys see
Christian Leroy Duncan do work but uh
homeboy blews me out so we have to wait
on that still a win got your first win
not the way you want to do it though
need some time inside that outcome but
what can you do uh Muhammad
um mokayev
um he won he won you know he's asking
for title shots stuff like that
flyweight he's not there yet again he
pulled it out uh in last fight again
pulled it out but uh slow young man now
he's going to be forced to kind of put
the brakes on a little bit because if
you did not see the fight uh
folio
filo filo uh blew his knee out literally
got him in a knee bar and fully excited
most guys would tap that's how much of a
bass Mohammed is here's the problem
though he posted a picture uh post fight
and his knees swollen up like hell knees
just don't swell up like that there's no
ligament uh or cartilage damage so I'm
guessing he's gonna be out a hot second
he's gonna look at his [__] freaking
knee there the knees aren't supposed to
move that direction so I think for uh
our boy Muhammad who's an exceptional
fighter and I do think he is Champion
written all over him this is going to
force him to pump the brakes a little
bit which just is good this is good
hopefully there's no crazy ligament
damage hope he just slows them down a
little bit
um Jack sure looked good looked
phenomenal Jackie short doing the damn
thing
vittori uh in Roman close Fight Man uh
that Roman is uh intimidating dude 30-27
ish I don't know I don't know just one
of those judges just completely off a
lot of the time
um but glad Marvin got it done I meant
to see what they do in the queue I don't
think he moves up because I think Rome
was ranked number six or seven so if I
think Victoria's ranked four if you care
about the rankings so four favoritary
four favoratory in Romans uh nine
actually so Roman will move down uh but
for Victoria he's not going to jump
Canada here he's not going to jump
Whitaker definitely not jumping Izzy
um then you have to Champion Pierre so
not a whole lot of movement for Victoria
he just said line him up I love that way
of thinking
um got her Nelson looked phenomenal you
don't want to really fight Gunner
sometimes over there across the pond for
Brian Barina he got taken down and from
there it was just I mean it was a
it was a master class his arm bar was
ridiculous so shout out to Gunner Nelson
uh best mustache in the game but let's
get to the fights uh you guys are tuning
in for so in the co-main event and the
main event coming event uh Justin gaichi
uh physiv my favorite find on the card
uh I thought it was a stylistically
nightmare for Justin gaichi I thought
that was it was headed that direction
for ziv was definitely the faster I
thought more powerful guy if you look at
the copy strike numbers it depends what
you
um put emphasis on when you when you
look at
um you know gaichi and Landing round by
round he landed more uh headshots you
know punches
um but faziv landed the majority of the
kicks
um but I don't think the judging is at a
level where they've um adapted and they
take kicks and uh take down the fence
and submission threats into account like
they should go to the numbers chin for
the copy strike for gay two physique you
see it's almost polar opposite where
gaichu is laying in the The Fist and
physique was Landing the kicks
um
so significant strikes
um get you through two more strikes at
171 for Zee 169 GT 103 physiv uh 97
um
this word gets interesting so uh faziv
you'd give him the first round right
um
kind of yeah you would because he landed
more any through less uh he looked the
best in the first one he looked great in
the first round right
um so there you have it so
um
when I and when I say leg it's a leg and
body so physique uh 53 uh targets uh
landed to the body
um only about 40 to the head gaichi at
78 to the Head
yeah it was a close fight I I think it
could have went either way I don't think
anybody got robbed it depends how you
want to score the card
um
yeah I thought physio in the first and
second I might be biased there it's
tough to tell I'd have to watch it like
three or four more times I thought was
evil in the first second lost the third
for sure
um but I can see how you would give I
guess get you the second and third
that's what the judges did for the most
part uh so for Justin again that
he's in a tough spot too because he was
ranked lower or yeah lower than him on
the ranking system so for gaichi there's
not a lot of wiggle room at 155
um they have mock Jeff calling out he
wants to fight Usman which would just be
a nightmare I'm sorry he wants to fight
Leon Edwards he wants to fight the champ
so for gaichi's not gonna jump poirier's
I can jump Charles Oliveira he did just
beat physive
uh you know for so for gaichi and Marvel
Tori four and three
you're fighting guys right below you
you're probably not gonna move up in the
queue there but for just engage I don't
think it matters he's must see TV so
he's gonna get some big ass fight but
again he's five doesn't pour His flat
Charles Olivera you know machev I'm sure
isn't gonna fight him right now so
that's a tough one for uh for gaichi but
there's something out there for him
they'll find something for him but in
the main event
watching it
um with my fam uh you know you distract
stuff like that
I thought tomorrow did better than he
actually did I thought Camaro especially
so the first round I give to Leon Lynn
looked phenomenal round one I give to
Leon round two I thought tomorrow did
more so I give to Camaro round three I
would have gave to uh Kamara as well and
then get the point taken for the fence
grab so then that would be a 10-8 round
so that would mean you have Kamara up uh
three rounds the one at this point round
four you would give to Leon round five
you'd give to Leon so I was like um I
think it's a draw
I assume it's a draw
then when you go back you look at the
common strike numbers you watch the
fight again
I can see how they would give around one
round two to Leon uh round three
yeah he landed more shots
um
you know
so if you give it to him that'd be a
nine nine round right
and then round four around five would be
Leon so
um that's kind of what I mean one judge
had to draw the rest had it scored like
that
I thought Leon looked phenomenal I
thought
um
you know they've spent what
um let's see they did three five eight
and then plus five here so they've spent
what was that 13 Rounds together
so they spent 13 Rounds together uh
prior to this fight they've spent uh
damn near eight rounds together you know
that last one with whatever it's 50
seconds left you know it finished the
round but they've still spent a total of
eight rounds together in this fight I
thought there was more of an upside with
them spending all that time together in
the Octagon for Leon Edwards as Kamar
oozman because Leon what he needs to do
is get better at defend the takedown
Kamara Usman isn't gonna bring anything
new to the table so you knew what the
exact version of Kamari were gonna get
it wasn't gonna be a better version it
was gonna be an older version and for
Leon knowing exactly what he was going
to deal with inside that octagon that's
why I kind of leaned a little more
towards Leon
and then also usman's not getting any
younger you find out how bad his knees
are you could see Leon kind of trying to
expose those knees which it never seemed
like a huge issue for tomorrow and I
know everyone says about his knees and
Kumar's even allude uh he was on food
truck a while ago about his knees but
didn't seem like it hindered him too
much and Leon was lighting those knees
up man another little break in the
program they'll get right back to Leon
Edwards come out who's been a UFC 2 86
the biggest tournament we talked about
March Madness college basketball is
underway the action is just getting
started out draftking Sportsbook one of
America's top rated Sportsbook apps
right now new customers can bet just
five dollars on any pregame moneyline
bet and score 150 and bonus bets if your
team wins plus combine multiple bets for
a shot at even bigger payout DraftKings
will be featuring parlay's odds boost
all tournament long it's March Madness
so be sure to check the draft game
Sportsbook app every day to see what
they have in store my team this year is
Arkansas they have two lottery picks
they just beat Kansas they are I guess
sleeper although they shouldn't be a
sleeper if you pay attention to college
basketball all my money's on Arkansas
what up download the draft game
Sportsbook app right now you sign up
code shop show that's shab show right
now new customers again can bet five
dollars on any pre-game moneyline bet
and get 150 in bonus bets if your team
wins only at draftking Sportsbook with
code shop show minimum age eligibility
restrictions apply C show notes for
details DraftKings
let's take a little break Tacoma see
this Thursday Friday Saturday Tacoma
Washington we will have tiger thick
there but it will be sold out by the
time we get to those late shows so if
you want your bottle of tiger thick make
sure you come to the early shows we're
almost sold out that is March 23rd the
25th Tacoma Washington this episode of
the shop show is brought to you by my
friends at Green Chef that's right green
Chef they expanded their menu now choose
from over 30 recipes weekly with the
option to mix and match meals from
different preferences in the same box
without changing your plan whether it's
vegan one day keto the next protein
packed we got it all for you guys green
Chef is the number one meal kit for
eating well with dinners that work for
you not the other way around green Chef
has options for every lifestyle keto
vegan vegetarian fast and fit
Mediterranean and gluten-free I have to
go with the protein box psoriasis all
good Shake Off winner with delicious
easy to follow recipes that support your
healthy lifestyle and taste tastes
delicious all right
um what I got for you guys I'm on the
protein box all right so go to
greenchef.com shop60 that's schab60 use
code shop 60 to get 60 off plus free
shipping the number one meal kit for
eating well go to greenchef.com shop 60
use code shop 60 to get 60 off plus free
shipping Tacoma see you this Thursday
Friday Saturday and Leon's distance
control his takedown defense was
ridiculous he looked phenomenal he
looked like the the best welterweight on
the planet
um so and then also bring up that status
engine this is insane I saw this on
Twitter
so uh let me see who sent it oh
um this is at uh vocara France so
clearly he's a big uh Aussie fan so
Alexander volcara France uh he put not
an old man sport
an interesting uh infographic inspiring
compile the record of UFC fighters age
35 Plus in title fights for the
flyweight division of welterweight
divisions all right so from flyweight to
170 not not middleweight not light
heavyweight not heavyweight when you're
older there they tend to have more uh
success the older they get at the
February divisions
um but so from flyweight to welterweight
this overall record is summarized in
Colorado chronological order from
flyweight bent weight featherweight
lightweight and welterweight
35 and over in title fights when you're
35 and over you ready for this they're 2
and 28.
if you knew that stat going into this
fight would you put more money on it
um it's It's just tough so for Camaro
who's I think he's 36 so
you know the you ain't gonna get a
better better version of Camaro and I
think this fight
um when you he's 35. so when he'll be 36
this year in May May 11th shout out to
him but when you look at it for tomorrow
you wouldn't even get a younger uh more
improved version over the last two
fights you're going to get a more
weathered version of Kamara Usman which
is a lot of trouble when you find a guy
in Leon Edwards that's why I kind of
side toward Leon Edwards there also I
didn't like the fact that Camaro wasn't
doing any interviews he was kind of real
quiet which is unlike him like I said on
last week's show last person to do that
was uh Ronda Rousey when she got dealt
with if you remember that so there's
some mental thing going on there I
didn't know if he'd be able to get over
The Knockout he seemed okay there he
defend the the head kicks really well
the head shot as Leon Edwards calls it
um but it was just too much for him I
thought Leon Edwards just put on a
master class his footwork takedown
defense the body the non-stop body kicks
or lighting Camaro up
um the more you watch that fight the
more you see line Edwards just putting
Browns in the back attack rounds in the
bank she did really well
um so you know I think for Camaro he you
know he says you know this isn't the
last of it I from what I hear around the
water cooler is he only has one or two
left
um that was going into this fight so I'd
be surprised what's left for him I do
think it can get dicey for him to try
and get back to a title shot I do think
there are other guys at welterweight who
can give Leon Edwards a much better uh
fight not that wasn't close fight but
Leon Edwards has Camaro's number and
also I think The Narrative of that last
fight the headshot uh the fight number
two being lucky proves it wasn't luck
when you dominate a fight like this for
five rounds
um no matter how you guys scored it he
definitely won you could you wouldn't
say that's a lucky shot after this so
kind of validate himself with that
um he's a baby face though man people
love this guy so for them uh you know
Hazmat wants to fight both of them the
same night of course because the
absolute animal uh the UFC's not gonna
let him fight at 70. he's gonna 85 and I
think Dana's in his press conference
said top three guy for him I'd assume
it's probably Robert Whittaker you know
the game Jr Canon there okay Martin
vittori you know but for Hamza I just
that one said he's too tough for him to
make so I'm gonna take him out of the
conversation for now
um so the division is kind of weird and
I thought this was interesting you guys
tell me if you guys Vibe on this
I thought it was interesting and this
isn't any hate towards Colby Compton if
I'm Kobe Compton I'm doing exactly what
he's doing get a title shot you want big
paydays he is a tough matchup for uh
Leon Edwards he's doing exactly what he
should be doing you know good on him for
getting tile shot would you guys turn it
turn it down so when Dana comes out and
goes you know Kobe's next in line for
the title shot uh no matter what happens
and he's there for the way and so he
said how long off
just not you know our conspiracies get
me in trouble sometimes and make
headlines but
does nobody think it's weird that the
mazva doll drama remember he's gonna sue
him for you know uh hitting him outside
that Miami uh restaurant all that's gone
away do you think maybe the UFC Went to
went hey draw all that stuff you come
back with your title shot drop all that
[__] because when you have moswell
fight Gilbert Burns we need to move on
this can delay everything drop it and
we'll give you a title shot because do
you think if you're Kobe coming to Inlet
put yourself in Kobe's shoes do you
think you're gonna make more money suing
Mazda doll for that incident outside the
Miami restaurant or do you think you'll
make more money fighting Leon Edwards
for a world title shot
and you know it'd be a tough fight for
Leon
do you think you're you the potential
make more monies in fighting for a world
title on pay-per-view or suing Jorge
mazvidal it's pretty easy to figure out
do you not think this is weird that just
went away and all of a sudden Kobe's at
the way we haven't heard from now he's
now they have the camera they're focus
on him during the fight after the fight
he's doing [__] interviews we haven't
heard from him at all do you does nobody
think that's a little weird that all
that suing business went away the
pressing charges it was a felony all
that's gone you have you heard anything
about that and then he comes back and he
gets a title shot
interesting is this
this isn't like a conspiracy of that you
the when you see I got in trouble for
everyone freaked out about where I just
said hypothetically
and if I'm if I'm Kobe get on you dude
I'm not hating on him hell yeah where
the per the only person that loses this
equation because everybody's winning
everybody's winning if Kobe does get the
fight against Edwards which he is it's a
huge fight for Leon because Kobe uh love
him or hate him is the biggest name he
can fight he's uh you know he he brings
eyeballs kind of in the Floyd Mayweather
way where he's the heel Leon's the baby
face that's exactly what you need to
sell pay-per-views he will sell that
pay-per-view Leon's not going to sell
pay-per-views he's just not it's not in
his DNA it's not what he does he's just
focused on being the best fighter he can
be and it's [__] worked out so keep
doing that so if you UFC you want the
most eyeballs possible you want to get
away from this you know the charges and
the felony and the assault and all that
and you need to use Mazda and Kobe so
how do you squash this all right mom's
at all clearly they organized this a
long time ago might as well it's going
to go away You're gonna fight Gilbert
Burns Colby you're in your title shot
cool cool go
that's what I think happened
yeah well that's a pretty damn good
right conspiracy slash Theory yeah yeah
although it does it because it doesn't
make a ton of sense that code would sit
out all this time and then come back and
get a title shot doesn't make a ton of
sense now I get rankings mean nothing at
this point and he's a big name and he's
the heel to this baby face and you need
that you know with McGregor Aldo uh
Chael sonen Anderson Silva DC Jon Jones
we've had this over time and it sells
papers we know this is a model the UFC
likes to do
but outside that it doesn't make a ton
of sense because there's a guy that if
you on paper you compare it believe
Mohammed deserves the title shot
right we all agree with that Muhammad is
the only one who's getting [__] over
this entire crazy
theory of mine Ma and it sucks for
Muhammad what are you gonna do with
Muhammad how many people does he have to
go through they're giving him shot
apparently which is going to be the
craziest thing oh my god dog
why what did he do to the UFC but be a
good person man
he's a great guy we've had him in here
he's awesome
fight 12 fights great you look at the
guys he's beaten they're still ranked in
the top 15. you'll get his resume like
what are we doing here
he's the only one that gets [__]
[__] over
he's won one two one two three four five
six seven eight in a row
his wins over Damian Myers Wonder Boy
Thompson Vicente Luce Sean Brady and
that Sean Brady remember Shawn Brady
undefeated at the time 10-0 Savage
[__] them up dude
man
this conspiracy theory the only one who
gets [__] over is which is such a
shame
such a shame
so I didn't think about it but then it
makes sense too because [__] I'm sure
more people want to want to see Leon
versus Jorge if he did a vote that'd
probably be the one or two yeah it's not
Muhammad's fault Muhammad is great on
the mic brilliant analysts great
podcaster checks is all the box from
Chicago immigrant checked every single
box
but unfortunately it has a tougher you
know a strength of schedule he's dying
around there's that guy should have a
Time shot before Sean Brady it's not the
business we're in they're an
entertainment business
when I saw Kobe went huh they must what
happened wait what he's just there
weighing in and he's in that sweet pink
crushed velvet jacket that's sick and
they're interviewing them I'm like oh in
the dance like yep no matter what
happens he's getting the title shot like
that's aggressive you can at least hide
in a little bit right be like yeah we'll
see you know we're thinking of your
Muhammad we're going to figure it out no
he's like 100 no matter what happens
it's Colby you're like oh wow that's
aggressive that's all but with the
felony stuff what happened to that yeah
you know I don't deal with that man
that's the police department okay
okay yeah and some of those backup
waiters they come in they kind of you
know sometimes they make ways sometimes
they don't Kobe was on the point looking
good man he's ready to go yeah
they didn't even call Muhammad for that
fight nothing he's not even in the
thinking of all this because they had to
get rid of that felony assault charge
and it happened and I'm with Co I do the
exact same thing and then here's the
other thing before you bring this up
remember Dana also
is on record how many times saying I
never make fights right after fights I
don't do that I never do that
this adds more
weight to my crazy conspiracy theory
this crazy conspiracy it's not that
crazy it's pretty easy to figure out
when you look at it it's pretty good he
made the fight yeah right after the
fight
and Kobe just came out of nowhere too
yeah whoa he's okay I thought yeah you
were like man I don't know if Kobe's
gonna be able to fight man that punch
[__] his tooth up it messed up his
Rolex he might have CT I'm like oh man
we when's the last time heard anything
on it yes he went squashed all of it
like okay and these pop that away yeah I
don't make fights after fights you guys
know this boom Colby Leon Edwards that's
next guaranteed y'all oh okay Muhammad's
like what the [__] speaking of Muhammad
he tweeted these these tweets here
so he uh there you go Dana White uh
committed to Kobe company getting the
next house shot no matter what happens
with Gilbert Burns Jorge Mazda doll
um or below Muhammad apparently Kobe
gets the next shot no matter what
happens is that weird how Adam and he is
too about it yeah and then uh Muhammad
put I never make fights after a fight
lol yeah you'll see Kobe if you drop oh
there you go there you go I'm telling
you this isn't hard I've seen way too
much first 48. I figured this out in the
first four minutes of this press
conference I was like oh I see what's
happening here so uh but uh UFC Kobe if
you drop the charge against miles we'll
give you a title shot
ding ding
ding ding you can even say it's
conspiracy not really it's kind of it's
like JFK it's like come on dude come on
does you want Jitter oh we proved that
thing a long time ago right guys come on
yeah there you go
okay salt
and Leon has no say in it just shows you
with Champs unless you're like a Connor
or John Jones you have no say because
Leon's like that makes sense the guy
sits out for how long he's he hasn't
fought in over a year she gave him a
title shot and that makes no sense
but then he was like I'd rather fight if
miles would all wins I'd rather fight
mazatologist because I don't like him
he's a weird dude that even Muhammad
makes sense
he says yeah shut your [__] mouth
yeah okay cool you're fighting Colby why
shut your mouth
interesting right very interesting and
then they're going to give Muhammad
or uh
White reveals huge Muhammad shafkot
UFC fighting I mean it's a phenomenal
fight
I think Muhammad beats him
and then what do they do
I mean at that point come on and also
when's the last time you saw Dana have
this in his head a book in a fight right
after fights which she says never does
he knew he was gonna get backlash for
Muhammad because Muhammad clearly
deserves the title shot and you have a
fight lined up for him so clearly this
went through your head come coming on
that stage man all right people would be
like all right we're gonna do with
Muhammad we're gonna be able to silence
that we get him shot which is so [__]
up
god dog poor Muhammad man I I put up who
how and I shot Khan's a Savage Savage I
thought last fight I do think mohammed's
gonna beat him but is there anybody not
rooting for Muhammad at this point
I think they [__] him over even more
than Darius
those two have been [__] over so bad
yeah that's funny oh no I don't get it
well I was a Savage good guy great on
the mic
great story
they went shut up here's shop got you're
like what I'm right the head I'm like
doesn't matter
Kobe dropped the charges
it's the world we live in
let's take a little break fam this
episode of the shop show is brought to
you by the one the only my longest ever
sponsor audit supplements listen I'm a
busy guy that's by Design I like to have
a lot on my plate and on it helps me
maintain focus in order to function and
stay in the zone my favorite is Alpha
Brain not just the regular brain but
Alpha Brain Black Label it's the more
intense Alpha Brain they've sold over a
million bottles of the regular Alpha
Brain and here's the thing if you don't
love it you get your money back no
return necessary keep your money that's
how much they believe in their freaking
nootropics the number one nootropic on
the planet it taught we're talking Alpha
Brain but I take Alpha Brain Black Label
Alpha Brain helps to support cognitive
functions including memory mental speed
Focus your boys always podcasts are
doing stand up and trust me I need all
the mental speed I can get all right
what are the benefits Alpha Brain you
asked hilarious AIDS mental processing
caffeine free helps with Flow State
promotes Focus supports memory all right
Alpha Brain can help you you remember
names places addresses all right focus
on complex tasks think more clearly
under stress react more quickly we can
all use this audit also offers fitness
equipment like kettlebells steel Club
maces sandbags yoga mats need better
nutrition say less Anna has MCT oil
protein bars Warrior bars uh they got
everything you need you can also get
your Alpha Brain off for bringing shots
you can do the Alpha Brain instant
regular Alpha Brain Alpha Brain Black
Label which is what I take all right so
go to audit.com
receive 10 off everything supplements
all the alpha brains the focus the
instant the Black Label the regular
Alpha Brain kettlebells steel Club maces
workout Gear streaming Fitness they got
it all go to onit.com receive 10 off
when you check out now let's get back to
the program
psych one more read all right I only
recommend products I actually use right
and this one I personally use I reached
out to them to be part of my programs
because I swear by this Kratom we're
talking about happy hypocratum this
stuff helps me tackle all the difficult
things in my life all right helps me get
stuff done period all right that's
honestly the best way to describe it
helps you get stuff done it's not just
some sort of energy boost or none of
that stuff you get a nice warm balance
good mood feeling for whatever task you
have that day all right my favorites are
the shots I use the butterscotch or the
Apple Shots but they have pill powder
gummies the shots whatever you want the
best grade one on the planet it's my
Hidden Gem it's happy hippo
happyhippo.com promo code is thick23
that's promo code thick 23 and they're
giving you a special 30 off this week 30
off the best Kratom on the planet at
happy hippo all you gotta do is go to
happyhippo.com promo code is thick with
three C's 23 for 30 of the best cradle
on the planet we're talking about happy
hippo now let's get back to the program
for real what else you got you we'll see
all right uh just here's a
the odds opening odds for Colby versus
Leon and uh Colby's favorite yeah yeah
that's a very tough fight for uh Leon
Edwards
very tough fight
at that at that level it's all about
style matchups and with Kobe's striking
his cardio it's a different fight even
though Usman beat him
Colby doesn't have the same miles as
Camaro Kobe's yeah minus 125 is right on
right now yeah so it was minus 135 but
then as it you know after a few days or
so and this is how it's gonna be freely
on entire time he his Reign at uh
welterweight as the champion he I would
imagine he's always gonna be the dog
which I'm sure he likes oh that was
another uh current event I wanted to
show you something about so Dana White
was with Teddy Atlas and Teddy Atlas
said something like when you become a
champion you're already 30 like more
confident or better okay like
automatically okay so that's why when he
fought Camaro the second time it was
like you know
you know what I'm saying like he just
his mentality everything was just
different where he got dominated for the
first fight but he came back second
fight and he was just like he was
dominating he's also different fighter I
can kind of see what he's saying he's
also you're talking when they fight when
you know Leon they're both young they're
fighting a straight wrestler
do you know why Ontario I was being told
Champions approved by 30. I believe it
is the old time trainers just tell me
that winning a title million proves you
30 let's see
Dan says I believe it I think that
there's absolutely a different level of
confidence that you have when you win
that type of fight I can't even imagine
the amount of nerves guests have gone to
that first fight that you might not feel
the second time and knowing that you
have the power and ability to knock the
same opponent out plus you've got to
look at Usman who might be a little more
gun shy if you think of all the wars
that he's been in with all the great
Fighters that he's beat this is the guy
who knocked him out yeah just you look
at the miles on this man you look at his
Style's not evolving you look at uh Leon
hasn't had the same Wars he does have an
advantage over with The Knockout that's
why I decided towards Leon
um one more about the fights so Justin
gaichi was kind of critical about
Michael Bisping and his commentary
versus you know
I
I love Gage I've been on a kid for a hot
second when he's in college I think he's
a little off on this clearly and I think
gachian alluded to this he's gonna be
biased towards his training partner best
friend right they came into this fight
um
I could understand the anger towards
bizbing if
if Leon lost the fight
there you go if Leon were lost this
fight and get like Molly wopped and
biswing's like no man I give it Leon
Edwards four rounds to one and the judge
have it four rounds one the other way
then you're like Jesus Christ dude chill
but Bisping didn't do anything that we
weren't all thinking that's why you love
Bisping he's not your suit and tie type
of dude he shoots from the hip also I
was I thought business was spawn he
stopped himself because DC was like hold
on he kicked him in the nuts dude you
gotta dress that I was with Bisbee on
this and I you know it's tough right
because DC is more decorated than both
of us by a landslide really me and even
more so than me more so the bismix was
still a champion but
um
with when biswing was going I don't
because remember Usman kept complaining
to the ref kept complaining the nut shot
defense grab kept caught talking and
business like dude you gotta just fight
like [__] all that noise focus on the
task at hand and then DC and then he
stopped them something she's like well
no you got a dress when you kick the
nuts like that granted it was a legit
nutshot I'm with Bismarck when that
stuff happens you deal with it and keep
going don't let it deteriorate you from
the fight or distract you from the task
at hand which is beat on Leon Edwards
taking Leon down I thought this was spot
on spot on I didn't I'd have it I didn't
think he was biased
and Bisping knows because remember he
did that mouthpiece thing and then Silva
Anderson Silva you need him in the face
yeah he's probably that's why I get paid
yeah yeah pay attention yeah hell yeah
that's a good point chin yeah I think
um
yeah again if if Usman would have won
this fight then you could be like oh
what the hell dude super biased your guy
lost too but I don't I don't see that it
doesn't make a big difference that he
actually won
Dan Hardy
uh that's basically you know
we all feel this way though like Leon
Edwards and even banil Darius they've
always been neglected
yeah it's because you know they're
they're looking for guys that check the
the all the boxes
for not so much on for Muhammad's a
little different because Muhammad takes
box he's entertaining and speaks very
well he's articulate I'm not saying Leon
Edwards isn't but Leon you can tell it's
just a more of an introvert he's not
going to come out and talk that [__]
into his thing even though he's a little
more talkative of this one Muhammad
he'll get he don't care we'll go so we I
I don't think he can put Muhammad and
lyanna with the same
kind of uh box there I do think Muhammad
uh it's a little more outgoing
um but yeah of course Leonard Woods uh
has been neglected yeah I mean I agree
yeah and then there was that thing where
Conor McGregor is talking smack about
usada I'm sure he's seen summon
headlines you want an aerial show right
and he was saying uh he has a meeting
with you Sarah they have a meeting lined
up and he's like him and said no we
don't yeah and you basically he was
telling Ariel that I just need two clean
tests where usada came out and said like
no you have to do that six month period
so then he was like who started you're
gonna be in the bin he's like I had 70
clean tests blah blah so he's going at
USA at a big time right now
that's what Connor does yeah so he says
you saw us going in the bin this is my
issue I've not lied once nor have I
tested positive ever I have over 70
clean tests under the program yet
they're consistently coming after coming
out after I speak in a matter that makes
it seem like I'm lying it's ridiculous
[__] you Sada you are in the bin yeah
that's what's gonna happen man I don't
anybody that likes you Sada hi there but
uh yeah so I guess even usada is saying
that he still hasn't
hasn't been tested yet or something he
hasn't like signed the whatever to get
back he didn't even started the program
yeah so
I like when they ask Dana he's like not
my job not my expertise talk to Jeff
novitski it's like but you hired
Nowitzki
you've commented on it before
and now it's just it's because he Dana
doesn't want to take responsibility
because what's going to happen is
Connor's gonna get that most likely
exemption yes
that's so crazy yeah
uh that's just them Michael Chandler and
Conor McGregor doing a Face-Off
at The Ultimate Fighter interesting
that's all
and then somebody got that simple Jack
haircut there oh and his facial
expressions Doug
it's a little puffy over here similar
size
yeah
um so this is
Jon Bones Jones
tagging Steepy milchich saying that
implying that CPA is not signing the
fight like he doesn't believe the
fight's gonna happen so it has to do
with steep base side I've always heard
of Steve said that's what everyone
around the situation told me that
steepe's not ready to go yet John's been
ready that's what I hear and Steve even
said July before so anyways so then he
put yo Stipe Only You Only You the UFC
and I know the truth you dodge me all of
2022 July September and December now I'm
hearing rumors that we may not be
fighting this July and then Stipe posted
a poster and he says see you in July
so I don't know what's going on sounds
like they're gonna see each other in
July
you think it's like more contract
negotiations or you just no I just think
you had Steve is probably like yeah all
right
see you in July dude yeah
so that was pretty cool and that was
like minutes after Jon Jones tweeted
that too he replied
so Francis Agana was also on aerial show
and he says Uh there's two companies
that he's close to signing with it's
either pfl or one championship
but he wants a box he's gonna do a
boxing before yeah and then I was gonna
say I assume that's because they are
going to allow them to do both oh yeah
it's gonna be in the contract where he
can go out and do his thing
it's a shame that he can come to terms
with UFC because what made UFC Conor
McGregor Floyd
so big was he had the UFC marketing
machine behind him
you know pfl is not gonna do that one
Championship is great at marketing
uh if it's against Deontay Wilder two
Americans you know they're trying to get
an American market so they're they're
pretty good at it at one Championship
probably is the move I think for him
um
I have I've made a decision without
making a done deal I know that my next
move is going to be I know that I want
to fight boxing first and then after
that I will fight MMA I'm going to sign
with one MMA promotion I haven't made a
decision yet on that but I'm very close
pflm1 FC right now we are very close we
will see oh I hope he goes to one
I'm surprised Bellator is not on the
table
but yeah I know
alrighty
all right whatever you decide to do
whether it's to be a third one
Championship all good you know but his
[__] you money's gonna come from that
Deontay Wilder Fury he needs that and if
he wins if God yeah good yeah but if he
gets that fight then him leaving the UFC
made all the sense if he just signs with
one Championship or pfl and never fights
Wilder or Fury or Joshua this him
leaving with a nightmare nightmare and
would you really want to see him with I
know Tyson fear is your favorite boxer
of all times would you rather him
because I mean I don't assume he gets
Wilder because of the he can actually
potential right he could win yeah he's
not being feared in any [__] Faster
come on and I love Francis but he's not
being Tyson
yeah he has a punch he has a he's still
a [__] I don't know plus
1700 1800 against Wilder but that right
hand water will play that game with him
Fury won't play that game that right
hand won't touch fury it's a nightmare
form
uh this is a quick one just want to get
your opinion on this so bkfc I guess
they had a a sold out this is what
they're saying they had a sold out show
on Friday but then because of unforeseen
circumstances they had to cancel it or
maybe reschedule it I believe yeah
reschedule it
huh so I'm like if it's an assault if a
sold out event how does that get
canceled yeah
um did somebody get hurt or sick in the
main event that was like the card you
know what I'm saying I don't know
so anyways it's gonna be it's going to
be rescheduled for April 21st 2023. I
mean can they BS about this kind of
stuff too I don't know well who's gonna
who's gonna come out and say no it
wasn't yeah right yeah there's no way to
check that
thought that was pretty interesting
um oh
so Will Compton I just saw him post he
was at the UFC pi and everything else
and he was kind of like at the power
slab events and posted about it so Dana
got him
they got him to go on this whole power
slap thing
yeah I mean I text uh will about lit him
up a little bit I said Jesus Christ dude
and he's like no man
it's open person I'm with it probably is
a good time I get it I do the same [__]
they invited me I'd probably be out
there now I get it I get it
yeah uh so this this you know we saw the
boxing card for Jorge miles it's pretty
badass right yeah so the price right now
is 49.99 that's a solid deal it's in
Milwaukee
yeah
and there's your headliner
Roy Jones Jr Pettis in Milwaukee the
thing's gonna sell pretty well
yeah especially because of Pettis I
think
um yeah so 49.99 not too bad jock Ray
Vitor
uh so Ben Rothwell he'll be fighting
that guy that just knocked up uh Greg
Hardy in bkfc the problem is this is in
Denver do you remember last time Ben
Rothwell fought in Denver it's Mark hunt
yeah
that's why UFC never puts fights on in
Denver anymore heavyweight fights
yeah Ben roethlis was a far cry from
Greg Hardy that one thing I might have
his hands full yeah a dude is Jack
though
he's thick for sure Russell's hairy
um
and it's at the same place they fought
hot and Rothwell fought First Bank
Center Broomfield
that has not been there now yeah all my
fights coming up for the UFC was that
First Bank Center is it huge
um I'm gonna price seats like 10 000.
that's pretty big
all right
um not a ton I saw that thick Boy Studio
posted this right yeah every two this
one Rampage no it's like him and Bob's
app walking down the street in the same
shirt and the crazy thing about this is
they did it it says here they're
training for Siamese twin fight at fight
circus six have you seen the fight
circus stuff before no it's insane they
do the craziest weirdest stuff and
there's actual real fights they do stuff
like this whether in a T-shirt and they
fight so many five people so I hope it's
not real that they're gonna be actually
fighting someone oh they will
100 Rampage went [__] around
Rampage also tweeted out he's releasing
his music I saw the Alien Song yeah hell
yeah oh yeah indeed this is so
ridiculous app's face I know Rampage is
so silly man
who the [__] fighting those two that's
what I'm saying like who could
something that's destroyed yeah some
dumbass can sign up maybe but then if
you're in it just go down the middle dog
and what happens let's say Bops at me
it's knocked out and there's Rampage
[Laughter]
yeah
it's it's a lot of fun yeah I'll watch
it yeah so they're supposed to be
fighting so many the rising or fall of
sloppy Balboa
who's sloppy Balboa now man
let's take a look are those two referred
to as sloppy Balboa
no well maybe they are bound by death
wow that's cool they're again the
Poster's [__] classic yeah
I'm gonna have to get that poster for
the studio
oh I don't know if you want to cover
this one
but uh I'll just throw it out there real
quick apparently UFC fighter definitely
or he was oh this poor Jeff Molina yeah
Jeff Molina is having a tough year yeah
he's uh linked to James Krause and then
he was in this column yep yep or so you
guys would know him mainly you know good
fighter too the with the James Krauss
betting stuff so UFC cut them because
who knows what information they have
there and then someone posts a video of
uh Jeff uh uh doing work on somebody's
weiner which is tough here's why it's
tough it's tough because
you know he came out and said he's
bisexual it's tough because if you are
bisexual gay with everyone you know go
about it
um you don't want somebody else to out
you like this you know it's just a
bummer I feel bad for Jeff I feel really
bad for the kid it's a shitty deal that
person released that's revenge porn so
that's a felony right so let's say uh
chin sent me a dick pic why me dude who
knows let's say chin send that big juicy
Korean dick and I blast on Twitter
that's a felony that's called revenge
porn so whoever did I hope they're not
hopefully hopefully they can track it
down and go after that person but it
just sucks and also with Jeff you know
um
you're you're dealing with a fan base in
MMA there's some a lot of great people a
lot of great people involved in the
sport but has to be the most talk to
take it from me it has to be the most
toxic fan base in the world because it
is based off you know forums and social
media and share dogs and all that [__]
so uh
for Jeff's probably the last thing you
want to come out you know and he goes I
want to be known for you know my hard
work and winning fights but now I'm just
I don't be known as the gay UFC fighter
unfortunately the way that the fan base
is and the way this works that's exactly
what's going to happen the other bummer
is is he didn't want it coming out right
like this
um and then all the major Outlets pick
it up
so you got a few Matt just put this is
my thing for anyone hating on Jeff
Molina why you [__] what he does with
his mouth and who he does it to is
beyond me I could give two flying [__]
what this kid does
um
but just put yourself in Jeff Molina
shoes for once I think about how he
feels waking up that morning and knowing
that some scumbag a whether it was with
a girl him hooking up with a girl would
suck B that you are bisexual and this is
how people find out
couldn't be a worse thing yeah couldn't
be a worse thing just put yourself in
his shoes for one second gay straight
trans doesn't matter matching being Jeff
Molina that morning
just be human about it it's [__] up
dude yeah it's not cool
so not to mention he's dealing with the
[__] with the James crowd stuff it's
just it's horrible a terrible time for
him so leave him alone yeah leave him
jerks not only leave him alone be nice
to him yeah give them some support he's
things are not great in the Jeff Molina
world right now with the Jeff Krauss
thing
um James thing then this coming out
sucks man has to it just sucks
and obviously people want a dog pile and
stuff like that so it sucks man
all right um pretty
that's it for current events so just
yeah one hell of a main event uh this
freaking is it Saturday Fight Night
great five rounds like God's five rounds
I wish my only
um my only complaint about the fight uh
UFC 286 was that physiv and Justin
gaichu was in five rounds
I think they should have the ability to
make any fight five rounds that they
want
but you know there's a method to their
Madness so they decide not to do it but
thank God this fight on Saturday night
is five rounds it's our boy Chito vera
for score sanhagen I'm close with both
these guys I'm not going to be biased uh
in any facet or give you guys a pick out
of both these gentlemen I've known Corey
since he was 17 Cheetos a buddy of mine
he's on the show all the time I won't
pick here it's a fantastic fight I would
assume uh winner of this does get a
title shot especially if cheetah were to
win Corey they might have him do one
more for Cheeto no doubt if he wins this
fight he gets the title shot so uh hats
off to both of them I just hope it's a
great exciting fight enjoy the fights
Holly Holmes back Andrew Lee's on there
um Alex Perez good fights nothing can
blow your hair back for that main event
you should definitely tune into Cheeto
Vera Corey sandhagen two of the best
guys in support going face to face great
[__] fight this one was excited when
it got announced and here it is Saturday
I'll be watching this in Green Room in
Tacoma that's right outside Seattle
there Tacoma Washington is this mother
Trucking Thursday Friday Saturday Tacoma
Washington we'll have thick Boy
available there I'm sorry tiger thick
whiskey available there
um so make sure you get you some it goes
fast we send four to five cases in every
city they sell out by the first two
shows so if you want some a couple of
early shows it's very rare we have it by
The Late Show so that is what it is get
you some though uh tiger think will be
there I'll be there uh Tacoma Washington
this Thursday Friday Saturday March 23rd
to 25th Atlanta Georgia April 13th to
the 15th before Atlanta I have one night
shopping friends at the Ice House on a
Saturday night April 1st is that April
Fool's Day
April 1st on April's fools
um ice house uh April 1st Sean and
Friends gonna have some monsters one
show only though I'll have that ticket
link up today uh Spokane April 27th La
Jolla June 2nd through the 4th that's
it's at the comedy store in La Jolla
California outside San Diego and then
I'm off to Europe in June you have
Belfast June 15th Glasgow June 17th
Manchester June 18th London June 22nd
Cardiff June 23rd Dublin June 25th get
you some at thickboy.com or fatkz.com
all right kids uh enjoy the fights this
weekend hell of a main event with Cheeto
and Corey Santa Hagen and uh that's it
like subscribe thanks for watching love
you guys be safe till next time I'm out